[Music]
in the last class we had
looked at
the furrow irrigation method
and
we had also mentioned that besides those
three conventional methods which have
become very popular over
the last many many centuries
the border irrigation
basin irrigation
and
the foreign irrigation
besides these two methods
are these three methods
there are some other methods which are
variations of these methods
they are also
being used and some places where the
situations
weren't
those methods should be
applied
either because of the the constraints
the financial constraints are
because the constraints of topography
or the soil type or the soil that all
those things put together they are
let's discuss
two of those methods
which
we had mentioned in the beginning these
are
contours
dutch
method
and the other one is contour leavey
let's first look at
in the case of contoured edge
what type of layout we have
and
what it is
suitable and with type of situations
this is the figure
of a contoured ditch irrigation method
you can see here that
as
there are
two ditches
there is one ditch this is another ditch
so what you have done is that you have
laid the
ditches
some ditches the size of the ditch can
also vary
depending on how much
is the
stream size which is
possible or which you want to use
these ditches are laid on the contours
and then
you while irrigating the area
you make the openings in the ditches
and let
the area be flooded
so this is basically
a method of
wild flooding
this is a method of
in which
you have ditches
which can be spaced
about
to 25 meters
and we go up to 100 meters
the spacing between the ditches
can be
varying between 20 to 100 meters
that means the area
which will be covering
from this end to the sand
can be a a wide area in case you have
the infiltration rates are lower
if the infiltration rates are higher
then you might
restrict the weight between the ditches
so that is that is up to the you have to
look at many other conditions also the
soil type and then the slope
the slopes in this case is
again the
slope variation can be
quite excessive you can use this
this method of
contoured edge
on slopes which are as low as 0.15
or even higher slopes
but again the restriction will be that
what is the slope
along with the soil type which is not
creating any erosion problems
and the stream size which you are going
to use they are they are comparatively
higher stream sizes
you are flooding the areas you can
afford to use the higher stream sizes if
the areas are flatter areas if the areas
are steeper areas you might
reduce the stream size so in this method
is not basically a
method which is a very sophisticated
method you are using this method because
of the fact that you want to
make use of the existing conditions
and you don't want to indulge
much expense which is
involved in
forming the area or
grading the area so the adaptability if
you look at
where these methods
from the adaptability point of view
you will find this
method to be quite useful
when you are talking in terms of
foothills
those areas which are lying on the
foothills which are
having slight undulations but not the
slopes are not very steep but the same
time
you cannot afford to
form these areas or relay these areas
because of the fact that the soil depth
is quite shallow so if you try to reform
these areas or you go in for the grading
of these areas
you will find that the
soil
the fertile soil will be
lost
you might be having a very small depth
which you cannot manipulate you cannot
you cannot
grade that soil because of
the loss in fertility and as such the
the depth of soil available is very
shallow
then
that is
involving very low cost
on those accounts because you don't need
any in this case there is no
land grading
required
the ditches are also
unlined
so there also you can
save lot of
expenses
then the labor expense is also not very
excessive because
the places at which you have to make the
the openings
as
is not a very skilled thing with slight
amount of experience you will know that
at what spacing because that will be a
function of spread of the water
up to which area the water can spread so
it is not a very scientific method is
only a method which
may be used under some circumstances
where
you
don't have any other
possibility of using the other method
because of various reasons which we have
just discussed
let's quickly go down to the next method
of
contour leave me
which again
is
quite similar in terms of the previous
method which you have discussed because
in this case also you use this method
where
the situations or the conditions
don't warrant any
land grading or land shaping because of
various reasons
and
in this method
you are not using
the ditches
but you are using the natural slope
which is available available in the area
so if you look at this
this is a strip
which is not a parallel strip as you
have in the case of borders
in the case of border irrigation you are
trying to make the steps parallel so
that you can have a very uniform
flow over the strip in this case
there is some
the
the slope may be in this direction there
is a gentle slope
so you have
try to
utilize that slope
which is
in this particular case the slope
will be in this direction because you
are supplying the water
from
some upstream end to the downstream end
and this
strip
and this strip you have not
you have tried to use the contours these
are the natural
contours
which
might be having some downslope
because unless the slope is there you
might find that the water might not move
in a in the lateral direction and
longitudinal direction
so you have to have some slight
slope otherwise
the size of the stream will have to be
very excessive
and the slopes are less the lesser the
slope to cover larger area you'll have
to have excessive
stream size but that can only happen if
the soil
type is
as conducive to that
higher stream sizes
so in this case you have the ridges
which are separating which are going
parallel to
each other not exactly parallel but they
are going along the
the strip
and on this side
you are
having
two ridges which are perpendicular one
ridge here the other edge at this
location
so this
channel can be used to collect the
surplus water which may be used in the
next step
so this is again a method of flooding
where
you are not flooding
in the same manner as you are doing in
the ditch and dutch method where the
water was flowing along the ditch
in this case the water is flowing
at some
field channel
which is at the upstream end so you
release the water from there it moves
into this
and
then the surplus amount is collected it
might go to the next field so is
normally used where you have the field
to field flooding
in areas
where
for example the delta areas
where you don't have any problem of
the amount of water available
in our kaveri delta
region
we are using this method
where you are letting the water flow
from one area into another area and
with the consequence that most of the
time the water might be standing there
so that is the reason that you are using
the
paddy
the petty crop is quite popular in those
areas
because patty needs the quite a lot of
water and in this method you can provide
that water because the water
is coming from one field going to the
next field going to the next field and
that continues
and
this
method can also be used for
other crops which are not very sensitive
crops
for example the grasses can be
this method can be used
the
other top can be uh for the crops again
you can use this method you might not
have that continuous supply you might
have intermittent supply
because the further crops again
they cannot sustain that longer
inundation
so
the
adaptability of this method
again is quite similar that you are
you can use it
for those areas
where
you don't have any
any
availability of excess labor the labor
costs are very less in this case
the otherwise
land farming cost can also be reduced by
not
grading the areas even if there is some
problem
in terms of the levels
you might since the depth of water is
quite excessive
so the distribution might not be uniform
but the same time
and
the distribution
loss can be compensated by the
the amount of expense which is safe
so
these methods
are
not a general purpose method they are
specific purpose methods where
you can
you can justify these methods in some
conditions
under some situations where either
the suitability
or the economic conditions of the
farmers
are
the type of crop which are growing
they are the
the major
deciding factors
so
with that
we will
conclude
the
the methods
which are surface irrigation methods as
we have defined in the beginning
we go down to the next class
of
irrigation methods which we were
which we had
started with
along the surface irrigation method we
had said the subsurface
irrigation
method
and this category of
irrigation method
we are supplying water
water is applied
below the ground surface
so this is the basic
difference between the
surface irrigation method
and the subsurface irrigation method in
the case of surface rehabilitation
method we have seen that we are making
use of the
gravity flow
but the water is traveling over the
surface of the
the
soil on the ground
whereas in the case of subsurface
irrigation
the water is not traveling over the
surface of the
ground but is travelling within the
ground surface
below the ground surface
now
what kind of method this can be
if you just try to visualize
you will find that
the typical
suppose this is your
ground surface
now if you
want to make the
waters
because the root zone that we know
there's the roots on depth
and which we are interested in
we want to
supply moisture to the root zone that
this area
because the
the plant root system
is
in this area
and
because of that fact
this needs moisture
in the case of subsurface irrigation
there is
a way out that the possible
solutions are that you either
provide that
some sort of ditch
you have a date
where you
control the water
you have a ditch
where you have
this is the water level
now this water level
is under your control
what will happen if you maintain this
water level here
and if the groundwater table is
somewhere
down below
depending on what type of soil you're
using
what type of soil is prevailing
there will be some
flow from this area into this area
some water will
flow into the
resonance
again it will be a function of how much
water will flow will be function of what
is the wetness of the soil
and
what is the relative location of the
groundwater table
and the groundwater table is very low
most of the water might
go down some water might go into the
lateral direction as we have seen in the
case of furrow irrigation
but this
situation
when you use the subsurface irrigation
we are basically using the segregation
when the groundwater table is already
very is quite high you don't use this
irrigation when the groundwater tables
are very low because in that case most
of the water which will be
making available in the ditches because
this water has to be made available
artificially you have to bring this
water from
some supply source
this source can be either the canal
water or it can be
the groundwater which you have pumped
and put into the channel system
it can be any any source
so this
the level which you have created here in
the ditch and
the level which is the groundwater table
if the groundwater table is somewhere
here
you will find that after some time there
will be some
level stabilization
if you keep on supplying this water
there will be some flow
from the ditch into this area and the
water table
might come up locally
now this
this rise in water table
is
within your control
if you find let me
put this here again
that if i have
a ditch which is
along a ditch
if i have
this is the ditch
now in this particular case
by controlling the level of water
if my
previous water table was
this is the water table which i have
established
after a long
um after controlling this level for a
long party period you'll find that this
doesn't stabilize the water will keep on
moving on this side and
depending on the soil type the soil type
is quite porous this might be
achieved relatively
in a quicker manner
now
if this is
the
the level here
which i have attained
it has become quite excessive
i can reduce this level
by removing water from
the ditch
this will come down
initially it will be like this
after some time
it might
become
this
and after some more time it will
this will be
achieved
this fluctuation
is what is in your control
and that is what you do in the case of
subsurface irrigation
the design parameters which you have to
look at when you design the subsurface
irrigation
are
what should be the
spacing between the ditches
is that will decide
up to
what level
the water table when you when you
control these
levels of water and the ditches
how much time it will take
for the water to drop down to the level
desired level how much time how quickly
it will do that because that is a
function of the soil type what is the
hydraulic conductivity of the soil
as that will decide the movement of the
water into soil
so depending on the soil type
you can design what should be the
the spacing between the
the ditches
you can also design
the other parameter will be what should
the depth of the ridge
that will give you the flexibility on
up to what level you can control that
the water depth
then you can also
decide on what should be the size of the
ditch so these are some of the
parameters which you'll
design
now this is one option available that
you have the ditches
if you want to
choose another option which
is quite a
usual option you might replace
these ditches
with
the circular pipes
you have this
instead of having
ditches you can have underground pipes
which are having
perforations
the water passes through these pipes
and it gets it does the same job
as is being done by the
letters
in that case you can save the area which
is utilized by the leches
so that much area can be saved
and this situation also again
you will have to
decide
what will be the depth up to which you
have to lay down the pipe what will be
the spacing between the
the pipes
and
what size of the pipe has to be used
these are some of the parameters which
will be
needed to design the system how the
system should be laid out
and that will be also a function of what
type of crops you are
utilizing
these methods whether it's uh
whether you're using the ditch or
whether you're using the perforated pipe
and a ground pipe
for the subsurface irrigation
in general
you'll find that the suitability of this
method
is quite
is not
used at many many places there are a lot
of restrictions in the sense that
you have to
use this method
where you have
the water table
is quite
high
you cannot choose this method with the
water tables are very low because
as we have discussed that it
lose lot of water and
as depoculation
you should use this method only when
the celerity is
is quite low
because if the celebrity is high
then by
what it does is that since the water
table in that area will be already very
high
now as you
use this method
the chances of
evaporation
because the water will be
coming to the
the top of the ground level
because of the capillary rise
that is one of the way by which your
your root system is getting water so if
the salinity is very high
the chances of
salts coming to the top of the
soil
is very high because of the evaporation
from the soil
so uh you avoid this method when you
have the low the
the high salinity
in the water
then you you should
avoid this
method
then
is suitable when the
soil surfaces
is leveled
because this method the type of control
which you are talking about
if the
the area is having a lot of slope then
the ditches won't function very well
especially in the case of ditches
you are
trying to have
the ditches where the water is
only being maintained with respect to
the input which you are giving
into the ditch
and the levels are maintained from one
area to another area
you don't make the water
run
with velocity
as only maintaining the levels of the
water so
most of the time you will try to use
this
this method when the level
the areas are very well leveled there
are
flat areas
and you are
you're not bothered about the flow of
water because
you are making the water they are all
interconnected ditches so once you put
the water in one location
the water will automatically move
into the
other locations also
and
this method is quite successful when you
have that type of topography
to give me an example
this method is
very successful in holland
in holland
as you might be knowing that the holland
the general level is below the mean sea
level
so there they are using a lot of dikes
to keep the sea water away from their
land
and there
for the florida culture the tulip
cultivation is
being
being done using this method of the
uh
the
subsurface irrigation method
there
you will find that
the water table is already accessibly
high
so they are controlling
the water in the ditch
and maintaining that level
either by pumping the water out of the
ditch
most of the time so that they can keep
the level at a desirable level
then
another suitable condition should be
that
the soil should be
relatively porous
so that you don't have to
use very small spacing between the
riches
your spacing but to have the spacing
large enough
you should have the soils which are
porous soil so that the water can
really travel fast within the
ground and it can stabilize
maintain that level which you are trying
to
control
so from those angles i think
you will
get a feeling that this method is again
a method which is
which has a lot of restrictions
and it cannot be a
method of
very
usual nature it is a specific purpose
method
with a suitability only in the
circumstances where you have these
conditions met
let's go to the
last class
of methods which we had defined in the
beginning
that was
pressurized
irrigation
pressure aggregation method
this method is
in general
is the one where you have
application
of water
as through pressures
devices
and again as far as
the distinction between the surface and
sharps of subsurface is concerned
this method is
in general surface irrigation method you
are applying the
water
onto the surface of the
land
onto the ground surface
whereas in some cases
you might find that especially in the
case of drip irrigation system will come
to that
you might be supplying water not exactly
on the surface but may be slightly below
the surface but that is again
the level
is very small and that is for us
with a specific purpose
but in uh even in that case it will be
called the surface irrigation method so
between the first two categories this
will belong to the first category
over the only distinction that you are
application
application of water is through
the pressure devices
that means ultimately when it comes to
the
application stage
is through the pressure device because
of that requirement
even
the previous system the whole system you
have to have under pressure otherwise
you don't have any other means
to provide that ultimate pressure at the
application level so
it becomes essential
that you have
the
pipes
the water will be flowing through the
pipes the source from the supply source
you'll have to carry the water all the
way
under pressure
so that
ultimately when you come to the
application level
you might choose any type of device but
the water should be still under pressure
so that you can
supply that water under pressure
so that is the basic difference between
this method and the
previous methods we have
discussed
there are many
different variations of
specialized irrigation method
they can be
different categories they are either
dependent on what type of devices you
are using or what is the order of
magnitude of the pressure
that is how the devices will also be
varying
there are many many
classes of such systems
but the two which have become
highly popular
we'll
we'll discuss those
and these are
first one is spring clarification system
and
the other one is
replication
these two methods
are the ones which are
basically the basic reasons why this
these methods have come into our picture
why they have been
they have come into being
is the scarcity of water
that was the basic reason
that
people thought of
different ways of
saving water
and by doing so
they felt that if they use
the
sprinkler irrigation
sprinkle irrigation in comparison to the
drip method the saving is not much that
is that has been found later on
but the intention was to save water
that was the first intention
but
the replication
as the further refinement of
not the refinement but the further
research into how you can save water
and those circumstances where the water
availability is
a limited quantity and how you can make
use of that limited quantity of water to
get the maximum or the maximum yield per
unit
water with that but that
objective
this method came into being
and israel is the country where
the sprinkler irrigation as well as
deprecation method has been they have
pioneered
these uh
the pressurized systems and even now i
think they are one of the
leaders in these
two irrigation methods
let's look at
these methods one by one
first let us have a look at
sprinkler
sorry
sprinkler method
and this method
the
water is
supplied through
the pipe network as
we have said that ultimately the
device
for application
to be used in this particular case is
the sprinkler head
now the sprinkler head is
a device which sprinkles the water the
name suggests that it sprinkles the
water
over the
the surface of the
the ground
you might have seen
the sprinkler
hedge walking in some of the like the
gardens these days or the
the lawns
and there are sprinklers which are
a very small
sprinklers which can be used in the
lawns which can be used with the tap
water which you are getting in your
houses
so the
those
that device is called the sprinkler head
this device
has a sprinkler head which is nothing
but the different types of sprinkler
heads
it is a device which
let the waters
go out
since the water is under pressure
it goes out in the form of a jet
and that jet is broken with some
mechanism
so that so that
it gets distributed in different
droplets
so that is the basic philosophy of the
sprinkler head
it
it disintegrates
a stream jet
into
smaller
water particles
and those water particles are sprinkled
over the ground you can either have a
single
nozzle head or you might have
a double nozzle head
where you have
two jets coming simultaneously
and
they are distributing the water
over the whole area
so this
this sprinkler head
it rotates
around it
it sucks as
in a circular
with a circular motion
and that motion can also be changed it
can be fixed
so if you look at the plan
if you have a sprinkler head here
the spread of the sprinkler head
will be a
circular area
and
if i look at
the distribution how much water has been
distributed
now this is the
axis where i have located the sprinkler
head
and that's the distance in both the
both sides
the spread
might be something
like this
this is known as the distribution factor
this is the distribution pattern of a
single sprinkler head
okay
so when the sprinkler head will be
sprinkling water in this total area this
is the i have taken a section view
at this level
even if you take
the section
at this level you might have a similar
section
and this is what
has the basic philosophy of what the
sprinkler head does
now you might say that
if this is the distribution
of a single sprinkler head
then this is quite an uneven
distribution
which we started with
thinking uh of those
methods by which you can have a uniform
distribution
for the total field for example this was
the field
we had uh
this was our
root zone depth we wanted a uniform
distribution over
this whole area and in the surface
irrigation method we have seen that we
cannot achieve this because of the fact
that the water
flows from
the upstream end
to the
downstream end
and that's why there is uneven
distribution because this gets more
water the upstream and
segment of the field gets more water
than the instrument
this can be avoided
with the
with this
spring clarification method now in this
case what i want to do is
i want to
spread my
if this is my
total
longitudinal direction
i might
try to
have the sprinklers heads spaced in such
a manner
that i get
when i
when i try to overlap
each one has its own
distribution pattern
the other one also has its own
the third one
and so on
when i look at
the distribution pattern of
the total combination
is the end result is
the combination of all these
distribution patterns and i might get
something of
this nature
okay
so is the overlap
which is important that how each
individual sprinkler head which is
spaced
at some
spacing
that spacing is important
that spacing is what
we are interested in knowing
that is part of the design when you
design the sprinkler system
later on we'll we'll see and there is
something which we want to look into
what should be the spacing
because that will be a function of what
will be the distribution pattern
distribution pattern can change
with respect to
the pressure
with respect to the nozzle size
and
these are the two major factors which
will decide
what will be the sprinkler what will be
the
distribution pattern of a sprinkler head
but this is the basic philosophy
similarly
this overlap
this is one overlap in one direction
the
let me let me put the whole thing in
plan
if i
if i show that field and plan
now
i might
locate the sprinkler heads in such a way
that this overlap which i am
trying to look at
which will give me a good
distribution
a uniform distribution
will have to be
considered in both the directions
so if i consider these two rows of
sprinklers
noodles
and i i look at the
the overlap of
both these rows
then in
in both the directions i might might get
a good distribution
of water which is the desired
distribution so this is what
is done
that you are trying to
trying to find out
what is that
now i'm drawing the
pipeline
for this
field and plan again
to achieve these
these individual
sprinkler head distributions
i might
have
i might have a
one pipeline running here
another pipeline running here
and
this might be the total layout of my
pipeline
which is getting
which is connected
to another bigger pipeline
now
on each
of these
locations
i have
these are the nozzle heads
which are located at some spacing so my
design parameters will be
what will be the spacing
between the nozzle height
let me say al
what is the spacing between these two
pipes
and each one this is normally
the nomenclature is that this is called
lateral
the electrical pipe
on which
you are installing these sprinkler heads
so what is the
spacing between the the
sprinkler heads why is the spacing
between the laterals
that has to be decided on the basis of
what is the distribution pattern of each
individual
sprinkler head
and what
spacings are needed
to have
a uniform distribution
that is what you do in the case of
a sprinkler system
and then the other design parameters can
be
the sizes of these pipes and because
that will depend on how much are the
losses
in terms of
the pressure variations
because
since we have
just mentioned that the distribution
pattern will be a function of the
pressure available so the pressure drops
very much
your
distribution pattern will be affected so
all those things will come to later on
but at this stage we are just trying to
see what is being done in this
particular method
now having known this
let's look at the suitability of this
method
what are the various conditions under
which this can be
suitable or
to
first of all let's look at some other
advantages
which will also
cover the
condition under which this method can be
suitable
what are the possible advantages the
first advantage is that you have
complete control on the
supply of water
complete control and operation in terms
of
if you want to
run the system for a very short period
you can afford to do in this particular
method which was not possible in the
case of surface irrigation method
in the case of surface irrigation method
if you
it might not be feasible but if you
are willing to
apply a depth of
one centimeter of water it may not be
possible
and
in some soils
it may not be at all possible because
while doing so
you might find that
you have created a lot of disparity in
the
and the amount of
water which have made has been
ultimately made available at the
upstream and the non-instrument
whereas in this case
you can run the system
for a very short period and you can
afford to apply an in-depth
any depth which you
you find feasible or you want to
apply that depth onto a particular area
you can afford to do that
then
the other advantage is that you can use
this
for
very
coarse soils
where no other method is suitable
because if the
soil is very coarse now in this case you
are not supplying the water from one end
to the other end
since it's coming as
in the form of rain
as the rain comes
you can you can apply onto any type of
soil whether it's a
highly porous soil
or
even if it is the other extreme
where you have very
low infiltration rates
in that case
what is needed
if you if you have very low infiltration
rates if you use a conventional surface
irrigation method you might find that
most of the
water is
getting lost in the form of runoff
whereas in this case
you can you can afford to
reduce the
the supply
but the design can be made in such a way
that the rate of
input or the rate of application can be
reduced
and over and above that you can have
more intermittent
irrigations
you can you can have more frequent
irrigations which is not possible with
the other method so in this case
you can have this method suitable for
very coarse soils
as well as
very fine soils
if it comes to that situation
but at the same time
if the
amount of uh water which is
or the
the level of application is very high
then i think it's not worthwhile going
in for this method
because if the
at the level of water application is
very excessive then it's better to flood
the area
than
going in for such a method
then in this case you don't
no need of
any
leveling
so the land leveling
you can use this method for
undulating areas where no other surface
irrigation method is
as
possible or is useful
you can use this method because in this
case you don't have any problem of
the terrain
as the application the rate of
application in your
is in your hand you can wait for the
soil to be dry
so that next time when you
apply the irrigation water there is no
surface runoff
in the beginning the infiltration rates
will be high
so
unless you have reached a steady state
infiltration rate
you will find that most of the time in
most of the soils the infiltration rates
will be comparatively higher
so in this method you can afford to make
use of those
advantages and you don't the
the mere fact that the leveling is not
required that is a big bone
so that i think we'll stop here today
and we'll uh next class we'll continue
with this and go on to the next method
of drip irrigation thank you
[Music]
you